THE SEARCH FOR SURVIVORS PRESSES
ON.
THIS AFTER A RUSSIAN MISSILE
SLAMMED INTO AN APARTMENT
BUILDING OVER THE WEEKEND, AT
LEAST 30 PEOPLE WERE KILLED AND
DOZENS OF OTHERS ARE STILL
MISSING.
MANY ARE HOLDING OUT HOPE FOR
MORE SCENES LIKE THIS.
THE RESCUE OF A WOMAN FROM THE
RUBBLE FOLLOWING SATURDAY'S
STRIKE DNIPRO'S MAYOR IS
ACKNOWLEDGING A HARSH REALITY.
>> I THINK THE CHANCES OF
SAVING PEOPLE NOW ARE MINIMAL.
MY VERSION IS THAT THE MISSILE
HIT THE BUILDING BECAUSE THERE
IS A THERMAL STATION ACROSS THE
RIVER MEANING THEY TRIED TO HIT
THE THERMAL STATION.
THE MISSILE FLEW BY AND HIT
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS.
>> UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT SAYS THE
SEARCH WILL GO ON AS LONG AS
THERE IS A CHANCE TO SAVE
LIVES.
HE HAD THIS MESSAGE OR RUSSIANS
REMAINING SILENT AMID THE
VIOLENCE.
>> I WANT TO SAY TO ALL THOSE
IN RUSSIA AND FROM RUSSIA WILL
EVEN KNOW COULD UTTER A FEW
WORDS OF CONDEMNATION OF THIS
TERROR, ALTHOUGH THEY SEE AND
COMPREHEND EVERYTHING PERFECTLY,
YOUR COWARDLY SILENCE, YOUR
ATTEMPT TO WEED OUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING WILL ONLY END WITH
THE FACT THAT ONE DAY, THESE
SAME TERRORISTS WILL COME FOR
YOU.
>> WELL CNN'S FRED PLEITGEN
TRAVELED TO THE DEVASTATION
LEFT BEHIND WITH THE DESPERATE
SEARCH FOR SURVIVORS.
.
>> THIS SCENE, APOCALYPTIC AS
RESCUES FRENETICALLY SIFT
THROUGH THE DEBRIS SEARCHING
FOR SURVIVORS, THE HOPE OF
FINDING ANY FADING BY THE
SECOND AS THE COLD NIGHT
PROGRESSES.
FOR SOME, THE GRIEF IS TOO MUCH
TO HANDLE.
>> SHE SAYS SHE PASSED BY THIS
BUILDING ABOUT ONLY HALF AN
HOUR BEFORE IT WAS HIT.
THERE ARE MANY FRIENDS AND
FAMILIES CLOSE TO HERE, SHE
SAYS.
--
STUNNED BY THE SCALE OF THE
DESTRUCTION, VERSUS THE
RUSSIANS.
I SIMPLY HATE THEM, CHILDREN,
PEOPLE DIED HERE, AND SHE CAN'T
SPEAK ANYMORE.
ON TOP OF THE MANY, KILLED
DOZENS WERE INJURED, AND MANY
MORE REMAIN MISSING THAN JUST
THIS ONE LOCATION IN DNIPRO
AFTER RUSSIA HIT SITES ACROSS
UKRAINE WITH BRUSHES OF
MISSILES THIS WEEKEND.
UKRAINIANS SAY THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN THE MISSILE
THAT HIT THIS BUILDING WAS A
SO-CALLED KH-22, THAT IS A
CRUISE MISSILE ONLY DESIGNED TO
DESTROY AIRCRAFT CARRIERS, A
WARHEAD OF MORE THAN 2000
POUNDS.
AS YOU CAN, SEE IT ABSOLUTELY
ANNIHILATED THE BUILDING,
BURYING DOZENS OF PEOPLE
UNDERNEATH.
RUSSIA HAS NOT DIRECTLY
COMMENTED ON THE THAT LEE
STRIKE IN DNIPRO, BUT THE PATH
MOSCOW HAS DENIED FORCES
RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
THE UKRAINIANS CALLED THE
ATTACK STATE TERRORISM, AND THE
PRESIDENT SAYS RESCUERS WILL
CONTINUE TO TRY AND SAFE ANYONE
TRAPPED HERE.
LET'S FIGHT FOR EVERY PERSON,
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAYS, THE
RESCUE OPERATION WILL LAST AS
LONG AS THERE IS EVEN THE
SLIGHTEST CHANCE TO SAVE A
LIFE.
BUT EVEN THE SLIGHTEST HOPE IS
FADING FAST, AND THIS COULD
SOON TURN FROM A RESCUE INTO A
RECOVERY OPERATION.
CREWS SEARCHING FOR BODIES
WHERE SO MANY LIVES OR
VIOLENTLY ENDED IN AN INSTANT.
FRED PLEITGEN, CNN, DNIPRO,
UKRAINE.
>> [SOUND OF ARTILLERY]
UKRAINE'S ARMY ON SUNDAY SAID
IT FIRED ROCKETS TOWARDS
RUSSIAN TROOPS AS THEY TRIED TO
STORM UKRAINIAN POSITIONS
AROUND BAKHMUT.
THIS COMES DAYS AFTER RUSSIA
CLAIMED TO HAVE TAKEN CONTROL
OF THE NEARBY TOWN OF SOLEDAR.
MOSCOW'S DEFENSE MINISTRY SAYS
IT DID SO WITH THE HELP OF THE
PRIVATE MILITARY COMPANY
WAGNER.
THE GROUP'S BOSS INSISTS, HIS
MERCENARIES DESERVE ALL THE
CREDIT.
>> FIRSTLY, FACT THE
MERCENARIES HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR MANY YEARS, THE MOST
EXPERIENCED ONLY OTHERS TODAY
IN THE WORLD.
SECONDLY, THEY FULFILL ALL THE
TASKS ON THEIR OWN, THEY HAVE
--
THEY ARE HEROIC PILOTS WHO DO
NOT FEAR TO PERISH.
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE LAUNCH
ROCKET SYSTEMS OF ALL TYPES.
THEY'RE A DEFENSE SYSTEMS WHICH
HAVE --
THEY HAVE TO RE-SYSTEMS ON ALL
COLORS, THANKS, INFANTRY
FIGHTING VEHICLES.
>> JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS
THIS TOPIC IS --
A DIRECTOR OF THE GRAND
STRATEGY PROGRAM AND DEFENSE --
AND PROFESSOR EMERITA'S OF
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS FOR
CITY COLLEGE OF NEW YORK.
SIR, THANK YOU FOR TAKING OUR
QUESTIONS.
LET'S START WITH THE ROLE THAT
THE WAGNER GROUP PLACE IN THE
WAR.
WHAT DOES THE PROMINENCE TELL
YOU ABOUT THE FITNESS OF
RUSSIA'S OWN MILITARY IN THE
SLIGHT?
>> WELL RUSSIA'S PROBLEM IS
THAT --
SETTING ASIDE RUSSIA'S THE
LARGEST COUNTRY IN UKRAINE.
IT IS ABOUT THE FIFTH OR SIXTH
LARGEST.
THEY HAD THE ARMOR AND THE
MISSILES AND THE HOWITZERS TO
DO IT, BUT NOT THE NECESSARY
NUMBER OF TROOPS --
SO THEY RAN INTO --
SO WE HAVE THE WAGNER GROUP AND
LATELY THEY HAVE BEEN IN TWO
PLACES, THE
UKRAINIAN-CONTROLLED AREA OF
THE REPUBLIC OF DONETSK,
SOLEDAR, AND BAKHMUT.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN PROMINENT IN
THAT BATTLE BUT THEY ARE
FIGHTING WITH THE REGULAR ARMED
FORCES REALLY IS DOING MOST OF
THE FIGHTING AND WINNING?
>> WHO IS THE MAN BEHIND THE
WAGNER GROUP?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE RUSSIAN
ARMY AND WITH LATTIMER POND HIM
HOME SELF?
>> HIS NAME --
IS HE IS 61 YEARS OLD AND HE
SPENT SOME TIME IN THE PRISON
AFTER THE FALL OF THE --
RESTAURANT BUSINESS MADE A LOT
OF MONEY AND BECAME A CLOSE
ASSOCIATE OF PUTIN WHICH HE
STILL IS AND ALTHOUGH HE DID
NOT COUNT THE WAGNER GROUP, THE
WAGNER GROUP --
IS ESSENTIALLY HIS PRIVATE ARMY
THAT HE RUNS IN VARIOUS WAYS,
INCLUDING BY USING THE GROUP OF
MERCENARIES FROM DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE WORLD, SYRIA,
LIBYA, --
TO NAME BUT A FEW.
BUT THEY ARE NOW ACTIVE IN THE
FIGHT IN EASTERN UKRAINE, BUT
THEY WILL ALSO FIRST INVOLVED
IN UKRAINE IN 2014.
>> AND HIS STAR IS ON THE RISE
RIGHT NOW.
>> WELL HE CERTAINLY --
--
OF A POST-PUTIN POLITICAL --
HE IS CERTAINLY ONE OF THOSE
POSITIONING HIMSELF TO
DEMONSTRATE THE PATRIOTIC
LEADER THAT HE'S A MILITARY,
LEADER THAT HE HAS WON FOR
RUSSIA, THAT IS PARTLY WHAT THE
WAGNER OPERATION IN UKRAINE IS
ALL ABOUT.
>> SO WOULD YOU SAY THAT THE,
ACT AND HE ACTS WITH THE
BLESSING OF PUTIN?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT IS A VERY
INTERESTING QUESTION.
LINES OF COMMUNICATION ARE --
YOU CERTAINLY WOULDN'T BE
DISAPPROVED, ONE DOES NOT DO
THAT IN RUSSIA, THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE SERVICES
AND THE PROFESSIONAL ARMY AND
THE WAGNER GROUP ARE SOMEWHAT
--
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND, THE --
ON THE OTHER HAND LATELY THEY
HAVE CLEARLY MADE IT CLEAR THAT
THEY ARE NOT ALLIES AND IN FACT
TO THEMSELVES RIVALS.
>> NOW, YOU HAVE JUST POINTED
OUT, I, MEAN THE OFFICIAL, ON
ONE HAND YOU HAVE AN OFFICIAL
ARMY, AND THIS PRIVATE FOR HIRE
ARMY, THE WAGNER GROUP, IT IS
NOT ALWAYS CLEAR WHETHER THEY
ARE ALWAYS IN COMPETITION, OR
WHETHER THEY COMPLEMENT EACH
OTHER.
ARE THEY ESSENTIALLY DIFFERENT
ACTORS, JUST BOTH VYING FOR
PUTIN'S FAVOR AT THE STAGE?
>> WELL, BOTH ARE TRUE.
IN THE BATTLES IN SOLEDAR AND
IN PARTS OF --
THEY HAVE TRIED TO ACHIEVE THE
SAME MISSION THAT IS --
BUT, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
QUESTION WHO IS DOING BETTER
AND WHO DESERVES CREDIT IN THE
RECENT GAINS IN SOLEDAR AND
BOND WITH THEY HAVE NOT TAKEN,
THEN CLEARLY --
WANTS TO CLAIM CREDIT, THE
MILITARY DOES NOT WANT TO CLAIM
CREDIT BECAUSE AFTER ALL THEY
ARE PROFESSIONAL MILITARY AND
THEY SEE FIGHTING FOR RUSSIA IF
THEIR BUSINESS.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, TO TURN THE
FOCUS BACK TO THE RUSSIAN ARMY,
NOT ABLE TO DELIVER A VICTORY
BECAUSE THE OBJECTIVE WAS NEVER
BEEN CLEARLY DEFINED, IS NOT
THE PROBLEM?
>> WELL, ONE THING IS CLEAR,
THAT IS THAT MR. PUTIN DID NOT
SET OUT TO HUNKER ALL OF
UKRAINE, MY BEST SENSE IS THAT
HE WANTED TO --
JIVE TO KYIV, TAKE OVER THE
CAPITOL, CHANGE THE NORTHERN
PART OF UKRAINE, AND --
MUCH MORE OF THE EAST AS HE
COULD.
THE TERRITORY BY VIRTUE OF --
AND THE SOUTH.
AND EVEN ACHIEVING THAT
REQUIRES THE RUSSIAN ARMY BUT
TO HAVE.
THIS IS WHY YOU HAVE PRIVATE
ARMY SUCH AS THE WAGNER GROUP,
AND ALSO THE CHECHEN LEADER OF
--
WHO FIGHTERS HAVE ALSO BEEN
ACTIVE IN THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.